today's topic one bachelor looking for
love will meet five potential matches
i'm in it for love i'm in it for love
i'm in it for love here's the catch some
of them are lying and trying to win a
cash prize can our bachelor eliminate
gold diggers and try to find a true
match or will they get played this is
love or money
[Music]
are you guys excited i am nervous you're
nervous
well this is your very handsome bachelor
zach hi i'm zach um yes hello i'm zach
um
zack if you do not feel their ties or
their breasts or their glutes
[Music]
we're gonna have a problem we don't have
a problem it is your duty
to feel the booty
pretty good that's pretty good
you guys don't know where this feeling
is coming from you got to watch the
previous one preach is not being creepy
for no reason okay
um wait can i feel everyone's arms
can i do that as you wish
you please man
oh my god stop stop stop stop
stop i'm 24 i guess i'm from grove city
ohio i'm a filmmaker and little actor
and uh kid at heart awesome what do you
look for in a match i look for someone
who can just have as much fun as i can
no matter where ever i go the girl with
the braids is definitely going for money
you think so oh yeah why are you saying
that
slap
if i go to the grocery store for milk
we're gonna be there for two hours
underneath your seats you guys have
envelopes and markers you guys can pick
them up and you're gonna write down if
you're in this for love or money
and once you write it down you're locked
in and you cannot change your answer uh
money
money love love and maybe love on the
far left she's a she's a wild card for
me are you hopeful uh i'm i'm hopeful
but i'm def i'm gullible that's one of
the biggest things and uh yeah
everyone's telling the truth yo why are
you looking at him like okay
you're gullible i could kill a boy
but it looked like yo that's
you know what he is he's the stumbling
[ __ ] boy
yes okay there's like this
that was that was accurate
and then there's like the drunken master
[ __ ] both who kind of just ends up in
the [ __ ] but stumbling you know what
i'm saying
sorry about that oh oh hey i like your
shoes i'm just cutting
the bowl and put this guard way down so
that you lean in and he goes whoa how
could i bring it
kind of kind of kind of [ __ ] me up a
little bit and i started like suffering
from a lot of self-confidence issues so
now i'm just kind of spending time
trying to find myself and uh just trying
to meet the right people and give me do
the same thing but with more more give
me like a little bit like good energy if
you will you know what i mean so i'm
just
i just want to meet somebody who wants
to like have fun because right now i'm
in a sensitive place
you see this face right here
[Music]
that's what he's doing on the inside
we'll find out we'll see if i'm running
hi guys hi hello welcome to round one
where you're gonna make your first
impression you have 10 minutes starting
now
well disappointed in her because she
lied to me she said she was going to be
by my side this whole time but
um like i need the pace right it's like
this is very just like general let's
start off with like a little fun fact
we'll go weirdest thing about you i
guess okay so i can move my chin
without moving my jaw and i don't want
to do it on camera but i guess i will
wait i might be able to do it is it this
that can we do the same thing yes
stop
you was so right what do you mean you
what i think we're so right
so right how did he go from
um yeah so that's the thing you know i'm
a bit gullible to yeah so okay girls
welcome to my party uh
you [ __ ] what can you do special how
how did he switch
[ __ ]
no
you were so right oh [ __ ] you guessed
it wow i appreciate that thank you
yeah you know what it is
game recognized game okay um i uh get
paid to work over summers i still so you
get paid to be fake
she's definitely there for the money
she larps you know what life thing is
yeah yeah live action role play yeah all
right sweet this is going so much better
[Music]
she said down
what possesses somebody to get the
inside of their lip tattooed
is it just the words i'm special
yeah you got a tattoo yeah where
bet you won't find where what would
possess someone to be like the inside of
my island like why
you can tattoo anywhere the roof of your
mouth inside of your lip of course
the palm of your feet the palm of your
hand
eyelids islands is a thing why
many people do it um i like diving
airplanes at the ground at like 200
miles an hour
wow
right now
in the future if we do date then you can
see that happen yeah yeah i'm actually
pre-professionally trained in classical
split ballet do it right now i gotta
stress three steps
we're gonna limber up okay okay
everybody's doing it i'm so inclined
zach
how do you feel i feel good uh 10
minutes flew by super fast it seems like
they liked you do you think anyone's in
it for the money anyone suss i don't
know if i can honestly say if i can
decide if someone is
bruh don't act like you're gonna think
this through really hard you're gonna go
with your penis
i forgot about this next part now i'm
sad yeah
that being said zach you have to
eliminate two
beautiful
limber
girls right now are you ready
my point that's weird but
i'm sorry
it was so nice meeting you i hate this
say it
second down
down down down down down down down down
down down
[Laughter]
i could see the girl just going by
people
and everyone else just like
what if one day she's walking by someone
she goes
down and someone goes
i'll say it
someone because someone goes
down and the sun goes syndrome
maybe there's a community of people who
get the inside of their lips tattooed
maybe you're one of our fans if you made
this stupid decision if you are
unsubscribe
when you said that he like wanted
someone that was like more down and like
more spontaneous i don't know i thought
we clicked a little bit more but um i'm
not like pressed about it i'm sorry
oh yeah no
[Music]
me no you're good
the break because the break was in front
of me can i just appreciate that the
white guy the only people left are the
whitest and asians
if this ain't the most stereotypical
thing possible this is round two where
zach will get to know his potential
matches a little deeper are you ready
zach yes you'll have five minutes with
your potential match and then i gotta
call it quits you'll get to peel them
back like a banana where are they from
yeah how many boyfriends questions all
that do you like bananas are you ready
yeah i'll see ya damn this man is trying
to shoot his shot as a little bit yo
listen get out the way [ __ ] what you
doing that that that's abby's big listen
do you like bananas so let's behave
yourself like bananas
big banana raised you
hello hi good to meet you one-on-one
good to meet you zach hi i'm actually
nice to meet you i don't know if it's
important but i'm a virgo
listen any guy who comes up on the first
date and volunteers is signed without
being asked
[ __ ] boy alert
moist
just like this
moist as [ __ ] okay ladies be super
suspicious if you see i'm a virgo a bit
shooting ass
he trying to get in them drawers and
then after you leave you with a burning
sensation he about to do a disappearing
act you feel me
i'm a virgo
what
what who is this
nobody asked
you need to stop [ __ ] dirty on the
floor bro you mean it's water the floor
gets thirsty too
let the [ __ ] drink
you know
yo leave a comment if you think the
floor deserves a bit of water for the
work that he puts in you show my home
scorpio
harping let's get into this because i am
i am quite this is this is a good thing
to know i was excited that you said that
because that's i feel like that's
something that someone would normally
just kind of like
we're going to keep that but that's what
i love about it
yeah i work as a flight instructor now
so i just teach people to fly but i do
competition aerobatics i just do some
like basic little like rolls and loops
i don't do that you get in the car
what's the first first thing i play i've
been replaying olivia rodriguez entire
album because it's a banger but um my
top three are
bony bear it's my all-time favorite
hiatus coyote and hosier
take me to church
yes
unfortunately for her she's not asian
enough so she's getting eliminated i'm a
nerd okay i'm a big zombie guy and star
wars and stuff i've suppressed it now
because my dad always said like no one's
always talking about that stuff yeah i'm
usually in a graphic you know what's
wrong with the guy version of this why
it's like we're all pretending like
these conversations matter yeah they
don't i took one luck at this lineup and
we already knew who the final two were
yeah let me see if i'm surprised let me
be shocked maybe you're gonna be
surprised okay because he strikes me the
type who likes the bok choy asians not
the crazy rich asians you know what i'm
saying yeah he got a type so you think
he's going to go for a plane he's going
for plane and larp playing in line
playing in lark playing alert okay
zach
hello how did it go round two i actually
really enjoyed round two i enjoy talking
to people you enjoyed peeling the
bananas can you pick out the liars yet
no see i keep okay so i'm gonna be
honest i keep forgetting that part of
this but keep your eye open you don't
want to get your heart hurt get to the
bottom of this banana bottom of the
banana this this but not banana talk is
sus super sus yo liz but you don't have
to explain this metaphor no because i'm
feeling one betrayed and two uh feeling
like i'm intruding on people's like
bedroom time what's going on right now
it's like you open the door and you find
your girlfriend and some random dude
banging right but the thing is they
didn't notice you so you just hear the
conversation and and it just seemed to
be both really into it you're like i
thought it was my girlfriend it's really
his girlfriend that's your girl because
the way huh that's your girl
but you know what i'm talking about
[ __ ] can i be creepy without you like
exposing me for a second that's your
girl what do you mean that's not good
that's what i'm trying to say you've
never met the girl it's an e thing it's
like anything oh shut the [ __ ] up
it ain't it it isn't easy why can't it
be either hey can i have an e-crush no i
got two of them who who else
uh
her first name sweet her last name
the comments are gonna know we'll just
leave it like that
the comments are gonna know
but listen the banana talk is kind of
it's intense
yeah yeah did you guys have fun with
zach we did it yeah it felt really
natural that was a lot of fun i like
that more than just facing five people
at once yeah that's valid
well it's about to be two
zack you have to eliminate one girl do
you know who it's gonna be she knows oh
my god i feel bad for my haitian
homecoming listen you know what
listen you do ballet you like music that
i'll never want to listen to but uh
you're gonna get eliminated this i hate
this just as much oh sophie
i'm sorry i know we have the ph bye
because here's the thing when it comes
to dudes who do these shows the choices
are obvious
ladies
remember when they said personality
matters not before the first date
[Laughter]
though
before the first date for the first day
that don't matter what matters on the
first date why even dating then
before the first date yeah
the amount of people that rejected me
is astonishing it's
there's
unexplainable
it's not astonishing people base himself
on looks this is round three where zach
will get more intimate with his
potential match zach are you ready to
get closer to them peel that banana just
a little bit just a little bit more
it's mushy too yeah it's like you all
right well you have 10 minutes to speed
date these ladies and i'm gonna go over
there
enjoy yourself
messed up the couch welcome to zach's
corner couldn't have been hilarious if
you just leaned over and sniffed where
she was
and i'm just saying that not because
something i would do yeah but it's like
she would you mean sniff where someone
said that because i like her no no not
where someone's at what where she's at
[Laughter]
get the [ __ ] out of here
oh i would literally do it for a meme
you know what i'm saying
like there's been times where i've been
on a date with a girl and they've come
back from the bathroom like which stall
was it
you said that
get the [ __ ] off of me man
you said that i said that cause like
you never
what do you mean you said that hey what
what which toy is like what do you why
i'm like
for my personal information what is
wrong with you
listen
anybody who goes on a date with me knows
i say a little bit of creepy stuff it's
fine
what is wrong with you
[Music]
you off welcome to my living room
it's actually pretty comfortable oh i'd
say so i don't know how to sit
i just like this is the default i'd say
whatever couch you're on that's how you
say it yeah 100
oh it's casual awesome so we have to get
personal
nice hello
all right i'm going to tell you guys a
little something okay
pay attention to what kind of hobbies
and what kind of work people do because
sometimes it can be super revealing
about him some people like damn i didn't
think this girl would be darren she
jumps out of [ __ ] planes
do you think she's a little reserved let
me tell you guys something else
war journalists okay
they don't mind taking off the condom
okay
i'm being honest there's literally a
study between like the correlation
of like alcoholism and like doctors
without borders and people who do
extreme work so uh for the ladies and
guys out there you know what i'm saying
if you want somebody who's faithful
probably don't pick from these
professions because they're much more
prone to being a little bit more extreme
with their behavior what about nurses
i ain't met a nurse yet that doesn't
swallow
sweden they're used to picking up [ __ ]
poop and [ __ ] thinking about i'm too
respectable pick up the poop
of course they swell
if you're a nurse and you're in the
comments tell me you tell me tell them
how you swallow
uh do you have any questions i guess
they um
[Music]
deep rooted yeah
i'm like okay
um
first of all do you want your personal
space would you like your hair okay
there we go there we go all right
perfect guys
what was she doing that push pull
when you get close but you didn't get
away just to like kind of confuse you
hey man what's her name she got a game
plane girl she bagged some hoes she's
been around the world and yeah yeah yeah
yeah she she don't bag some hoes how
many relationships have you been in um
i've been in about two serious ones so i
only really do serious pretty guarded
too so i think i kind of just close out
people pretty easily that's probably why
i've only been into relationships or i
don't know and since i just moved down
here like i really don't know anybody
yeah you said you've uh it's been a
month you've been here right yeah yeah
it's been hard good yeah i like it she
said like that's probably why i've only
been into a relationship i'm kind of
[ __ ] up and everyone at home is like
i've never been
a lot of people a lot of people are in
the comments and if you felt triggered
by that comment i'm talking to you
if you feel triggered by this you should
be shitty
i was having a conversation with
somebody on ig live and they said how
old does someone have to be before like
not having a relationship is a red flag
to you and i said 28 the comments lost
their [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] i just said hey we're
gonna have a conversation i didn't say
you're [ __ ] broken or defective i
just said why haven't you gotten that
relationship by 28
they washed their mind of course
especially the this age 28
20 into this age
2021 what are you trying to say what's
underneath that little smile
that that generation is garbage it's
millennials you're probably not you're a
millennial too i'm the last [ __ ] i'm
actually zenellio
shut up
look it up shut up look at it i'm not
looking that up because that's a stupid
name so even if it's real it shouldn't
exist yeah i understand all right but
you're a millennial
it's a nano
no matter how many times you say it's
not going to stick so now yeah can
everybody comment let priests know he's
a millennial i am yeah
yeah okay talk [ __ ] about this
generation it's you too yes yeah
hold on hold on hold on
yes yeah this generation is garbage yeah
oh your generation
i'm not going to throw my millennials
under the bus we were great
we are okay we were great
don't don't let them don't talk to you
right now uh
have you ever been cheated on yes you
have yeah how was that because i don't
like that um
millennials
come on you know what this generation
does suck i'm sorry man i owe you an
apology bro yeah i'm sorry bro
i'm [ __ ] up
after i went to bed for this
relationship
after i defended these [ __ ] i
defended him
you saw that right we were rooting for
you
and this [ __ ] goes will you have
a cheetah because because that really
sucks
because i don't really like that
jesus christ um it was my first
relationship and so it was kind of like
rough yeah it definitely
like affected me a lot it's trust issues
like i get worried yeah yeah no i feel
like uh i'm the same way because i was
cheated on two and that stuff that has
repercussions which it hurts it
literally it'll affect you for whatever
however long time goes by because i
don't ever want to put someone through
that yeah i just feel like um if it's
not
sorry wait i like sorry i like rushed
back with my thought after that
yeah yeah okay well nice to talk to you
thank you for coming absolutely to my
chair yeah thanks for having me
how did it go for you uh it went well to
know someone's fears and stuff like that
about relationships or things they've
went through i think is a big part of if
you do move forward with someone yeah
are you leaning towards a certain girl
yes
all of our interactions have been very
like relaxed laid back in the sense of
like you are talking to a friend do you
think your choice is in it for love or
money
she i think my choice is very hot
this is pretty much the way this is
that's the way this whole thing went i'm
gonna be honest i feel like there's
she's the one that has the potential
that could be in it for money zach
you're going to have to go with your
heart
and choose who you want to go on another
date with remember both of them can be
in it for love both can be in it for
money or one can be in it for love and
one could be in it for money
i want to go on a date with you
[Music]
i'm so sorry
i'll see myself out it was great
bye it's nice meeting you meet you all
right hey hi
hi i'm zach hello i'm ashley
i think it went pretty good um didn't
win
or anything but i think i kind of made
my way in there and did the best i could
did you think you were gonna win i kind
of did yeah what
every time i hear making my way
is it just me is it just me though like
no real time when you hear a girl
especially a white girl say making my
way downtown riding around
that track is fire though
but that's the thing about this track
this one amongst a few other tracks
where like black people know but we
don't openly broadcast that we know the
only reason we know is because of terry
crews you know when we used to like
terry crews oh yeah yeah white girls
yeah because of white girls yeah yeah so
that's the reason why we like that that
[ __ ] because it was on the radio a lot
but we like like it but it was also kind
of catchy the way in brothers did that
yeah i'm not mad at that white girl
shout out to them time to find out if
ashley was in it for love
or for money
do you
think you made the right choice
she regrets oh no well this is love or
money and here is your envelope to
reveal what you chose okay yo she is
really good at larping because she's
pretending she has a soul and she's
still going right now
girl just take your money and leave be
the suckiest that you are
[Music]
i'm so sorry it's okay it's okay it's
okay yeah i mean that's that's i have to
cut you guys off you can't ask for his
number you can't ask for his social
media okay i just have to walk you out i
like elizabeth slide again like no [ __ ]
you lost your chance it's mine now
if we're being honest elizabeth has been
kind of sabotaging this whole day she
has because in between instead of asking
him relevant questions she'd been
flirting and i'm not going to lie to you
that offends me it's just a vegetable no
no it offends me don't ask questions how
am i back [ __ ] i'm not what what do you
mean she's just bad how are you gonna
take her side cause you you yo because
you're no no [ __ ] no no no no [ __ ] no
that's mine what the
what's yours
you should have my back no i don't what
you mean no no i shouldn't
this is why black people never work
together
where you're supposed to have mavic what
the [ __ ] are you talking about you just
mad because that girl's not on your side
she's not nationwide that's why
nationwide is on your side you're a
piece of [ __ ]
two pieces
[Music]
be on your side yeah you know what she
is allstate
because she for everything oh no she's
what's in your wallet
because she saw somebody
i'm so sorry
and then i just
does it rain money on me or something
like that
[Music]
like i said these ones are obvious
anybody who's crazy enough to
to get their [ __ ] bottom lip tattooed
is definitely crazy enough to go on the
show looking from us again anybody's
really crazy to you know be infatuated
with a girl from outside of the country
that you don't even know if she's not in
the jubilee never mind going hell yeah
listen bruh rough can i can i live
with allies like you who needs enemies
[ __ ]
what you talking about excuse me
talking about yeah yeah yeah okay
whatever
oh that one surprise oh
i picked everyone else except for that
one no that one surprised me you know
the only disappointing about this girl
winning she didn't know how to enjoy it
like the other white dude with the
blonde hair he's like i'm going on
vacation about to spend this money on
myself it's a hundred bucks it's like a
vacation yeah no it's a few hundred it's
a hundred no no there's a few hundred
it's a hundred twenty dollar bills these
are hundreds there's a few of them oh
[ __ ] yeah i thought it was just 100 no
no no no no no they got money but that's
my thing for that much amount of money
it deserves a little bit of celebration
yeah right
can you play a little jam yeah can we
celebrate
okay
girl
you larping you larping you larping
pretending like you got it you sharpened
ah okay i i typically don't go off of
like looks when i'm like talking to
people initially but um we just you know
mesh well i feel like he's he's really
funny it's unlike you guys were
connecting so well yeah but that
happened after uh
yeah
we'll pay it it's fine it's fine if i
suppress it it's okay fine you're fine
zack you're back you're back and you
don't have a love
just left how i was coming in well i
remember saying i said like definitely i
feel like there's a chance that she was
in it for uh the money but i don't feel
like sad like i wasn't in the background
crying i heard a little like whimpering
but you know i i think i was like you
know just doing the thing
let's go peel that banana off
oh terrible i need to this video
[Music]
you know
that's life guys
sometimes you're like making your way
downtown to go see your gums she's just
peeling someone else's banana you know
and that's life
that's life she's a minion and that just
be a symbol
let this be a a a lesson to everybody at
home right
don't sip okay
what none go ahead
it's all you another lesson to learn if
you guys looked at who picked the money
all the immigrants were down for love
and the white women couldn't be trusted
so hopefully you guys take that in
ingest it because this is why i tell
everybody listen behind closed doors
love them is what you want but in the
streets you can't do it because they'll
choose the money they'll go straight for
your wallet um you're just trying to get
me back for that [ __ ] [ __ ] what do
you mean
nationwide
the copper zoids will be the cop resorts
let it be known just wanted to let you
guys know
i was gonna tell you to trust the
sisters but then after elizabeth didn't
be dirty like that it is what it is so
she didn't do you dirty she did she did
i don't want to hear from you can i not
cannot can i not hear it from you
can i not
for two
minutes okay okay let me live with my
pain and then tomorrow you can tell me
what you want to say okay no problem
it's too soon yeah you understand that
right it literally just happened and
you're over here being like you dominic
can i just mourn more okay
she out here peeling bananas are you
trying to tell me the truth you come on
can i have my apple go ahead all right
there more than a relationship that
never happened
corny ass [ __ ] yo listen yo get out of
here you get to get out of here go open
that door open that door leave go
yay
it's just you
and the floor and the floor and the
floor
yeah yeah
whatever [ __ ]
anyways this [ __ ] over here thought
about it
don't listen to him okay
to listen to him
don't listen to him
[Music]
[Applause]
a
[Music]
i